hunter biden is caught on tape telling a
prostitute about his prior laptop
problems despite another bad inflation
report the biden administration keeps
blowing out the spending and the
lockdown crowd has no answers but lots
of momentum i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
the men shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and i have some rather
stirring news on hunter biden to get to
first you should actually save money by
going and switching your cell phone
coverage over to pure talk usa it's a
thing that you should do right now
you're spending too much money on your
cell phone coverage if you're with
verizon or att or t-mobile you are just
paying too much i want you to switch
over to puretalk today because pure talk
could save your family over 800 a year
yes same great coverage because puretalk
is on the exact same network as one of
the big three but at a fraction of the
price and switching is as easy as
switching out your sim card you can keep
your phone keep your number or get
enormous discounts on the latest iphones
and androids plus right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on the data they don't charge you
for it there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs why they are the
preferred wireless partner of a mac from
your cell phone dial pounds at 250 save
ben shapiro to get started save an
additional 50 off your very first month
that is pound 250 say ben shapiro to get
started and again you're not just saving
50 on your first month you could be
saving hundreds of dollars a year like
up to 800
a year or more from pure talk usa go
check them out right now alrighty so
hunter biden is apparently the smartest
person that joe biden knows which is
incredible because what this means is
that joe biden just spends his days
hanging around five-year-olds that is
the only plausible explanation for how
hunter biden is the smartest person that
he knows because kids are unintelligent
and hunter biden is really unintelligent
and so i have picked the age of five
because if you go to the age of six
hunter biden still would not be the
smartest person that joe biden knows
so now we have this story about hunter
biden
in which she violates all the rules of
prostitution according to the uk daily
mail hunter biden claimed that russians
stole one of his laptops for blackmail
while he was close to overdosing in a
las vegas hotel room the daily mail can
reveal
the alleged incident would mean hunter
lost a total of three computers the
first abandoned delaware computer store
the second seized by federal agents like
this is a weird way to lose computers by
the way like if you've ever lost a
computer it's usually like you were on a
plane and then you just forgot it there
but to lose three
and the first one
you abandoned at a computer store and
just forgot about it and the second one
was used by federal agents and the third
was stolen by the russkies i will say
your record with computers is extremely
poor and you really should think about a
more mobile form of technology at this
point
the third laptop apparently is still
missing it was taken by russian drug
dealers after they partied with hunter
in vegas he told a prostitute in a
conversation caught on camera
so here's what happened he filmed
himself having sex with the woman using
his laptop in january 2019 and then
decided you know what we need like some
after role here right it's like the
after the credits section of the sex
tape he left the camera rolling as he
recounted a vegas bender in which he
spent 18 days going around from
penthouse suite to penthouse suite
sometimes costing ten thousand dollars a
night but don't worry guys he is very
well qualified he earned all that kind
of money by being the smartest person
that joe biden knows he didn't use the
biden name in any way shape or form to
get extremely wealthy and then use all
of that money on coke-fueled binges with
multiple prostitutes moving hotel the
hotel
no he's just he's brilliant i mean like
in joe biden's rolodex of brilliant
people that he knows and there's so many
brilliant people he knows i mean his
wife is a doctor for one i mean like the
greatest doctor in all the land and then
you've got hunter who is just a
world-beating businessman like an
incredible incredible businessman
it's it's really an impressive it's an
impressive show so here was a little bit
of what it sounded like when a hunter
was speaking to this prostitute who had
to be like god you're so boring but
you're also paying me two thousand
dollars an hour
ugh i can't like i can't even but at the
same time the money is so good and if i
tell him that this can of parmesan
cheese that i just picked up at the
grocery is coke he will hand me another
hundred thousand dollars so the
prostitute is very uh i would say lax in
in allowing him to speak to her this way
here's what the tape sounded like
my computer
had taken tons of like
um like just left that like that came on
he would always put him like a passcode
what does the computers have to do
they have videos of me doing this
there is me doing
crazy effing sex and she's like well
then what did you just pay me for so
that's weird
and also
the p-tape is real but it stars hunter
biden now the reason we're leading with
this story is number one because it's
hilarious but number two
because if this were donald trump jr you
know that it would lead every network
news
hour for like the next month but it's
hunter biden so he's just a wayward
child guys he's just a small child who's
51 years old
he's just a very small wayward child
he's 14 years my senior that's all
and who happens to be like one of the
worst people i've ever heard of
but also the smartest person that joe
biden knows and who is still going
around like picking up bags of cash
based on his daddy's last name although
now he's become a great artist we know
right he which explains the dissolution
usually you have to be the artist first
before he can be a dissolute artist but
he actually started with the dissolution
and then he became an artist which is
actually going at its sort of ass
backwards right he started off with the
coke-fueled binges and the and the
benders with prostitutes and then he
moved into making crappy art as opposed
to usually it's the other way around
which is you start off as an artist and
then you like move into the artist
dissolute lifestyle so you know he he
really likes to do everything i think in
in new and interesting ways so a few
things about this one
my understanding is that this means he's
violated like all of the rules of
prostitution okay so hugh grant famously
suggested about prostitution right he
was dating elizabeth hurley you'll
recall he was married to elizabeth
hurley at the time he'd been married um
but he was at least dating her at the
time and he was stupid prostitutes on
the side and everybody was like wait up
you're married to elizabeth hurley and
you are going to prostitutes and hugh
grant his line about this was i don't
pay them for the sex i pay them to leave
okay well
okay fair enough apparently hunter biden
never really got the message and so he
just talks to the prostitutes also which
is like
okay
all right okay so he's violating all the
rules of prostitution as i understand
them and granted i'm not the world's
greatest expert on prostitution but i
feel like these are fairly ironclad
rules one don't use them
two if you are going to use a prostitute
don't talk to them about all your life
problems because you're literally having
to pay them for sex so they don't care
about them and they probably are not
great repositories of information like i
don't think that they are big on the nda
per se like
it doesn't seem like the most
trustworthy crowd i mean i'll be honest
with you okay and then number three if
you are going to talk about all your
life problems being a famous person like
hunter biden if you are in fact going to
do that then probably don't talk on tape
on a laptop right that's rule number
three rule number four if you are going
to one have sex with a prostitute two
talk to the prostitute about all your
life problems three do all of it on tape
on your laptop
then four what you should talk about
should not be
how your prior laptops have been stolen
to your great discontent
because
that creates a sort of incentive
structure for people to steal your
laptop
and uh it turns out of course that this
laptop did not end up in his hands just
like every other laptop so guys if
you're ever at the airport and you see
hunter biden there and you really have
to go to the bathroom and your laptop is
in your backpack do not ask hunter biden
to watch your backpack do not do it it
is not going to end well in any way
shape or form
what a what a delight hunter biden is
and by the way if you ask questions
about this this means you're bad
how dare you because hunter biden is a
wonderful wonderful man and we know he's
a wonderful man because his last name is
biden and joe biden is a wonderful man
my favorite part of this this is really
great the prostitute asked hunter if he
was worried remember he said that he had
a laptop and the russians stole it quote
from the daily mail the prostitute asked
hunter if he was worried the russian
alleged thieves would try to blackmail
him
hunter replied yeah in some way yeah my
dad is running for president he is i
talk about it all the time if they do
he also knows i i make like a gazillion
dollars
hunter appeared to be dismayed that if
the video was sold by the alleged
thieves to porno news companies he would
be unable to cash in on the explicit
videos himself yeah because there's a
huge market it turns out for hunter
biden sex tapes it's like one night in
paris except with a slightly overweight
dissolute politician's son
the huge market for that sort of thing
he said quote i'm worried he gets the
money up front and maybe it doesn't do a
million dollars maybe it does three
maybe nobody wants to see me naked maybe
it's news interest and because my dad's
a public figure they say we don't have
to pay you anything because you're of
interest in regular news the prostitute
said i think you should just beat him to
the punch i think you should release
your own video
that's spectacular
okay like i love that hunter biden the
smartest person that joe biden knows his
big business idea is what if i screw a
prostitute put it on my laptop and then
sell the tape
no
i i guarantee you know there's a breed
of man
when he's dating a woman or when he's
trying to date a woman he's not even
dating her when he's trying to date a
woman he thinks that the best available
thing that he can do to woo a woman is
to send a picture of his
right there is that breed of man and
i've always thought who is that guy like
who was the guy who thought you know
what what what this random woman really
wants is a picture of mine we know who
the guy is now the guy's hunter ryden
right he's like i have a money making
proposition for you prostitute lady my
money-making proposition is
we go halsey's on the sex and then we
also go halsey's on the sex tape or i
pay you nothing
but my favorite part there is where she
asks him explicitly
aren't you afraid you'll be blackmailed
and he's like yeah and she's like cool
isn't that what's going on i like
yeah it's it's not it's not good
okay by the way photos on the laptop
hard drive obtained by the daily mail
include pictures of a woman's russian
passport and photos of hunter topless
pulling the woman's brunette hair while
she kneels on a bed other photos show
the woman and three young men driving to
hunter's former hollywood hills rented
home drinking and partying by the pill
by the pool and two women naked with
hunter by the pool it's unclear whether
the russian woman and three men are the
same people hunter accused of stealing
his laptop so the good news is that that
all got uh sent to the cloud so
apparently he could redownload that to
the new computer to make sure that he
had it with him wherever he went now
some people we like to have pictures of
our wives and our kids on the cloud
hunter has very important things like
random people he has sex with and does
drugs with on the cloud
ah
well
at least he's not the president's son
at least that
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the inflation record of the biden
administration and now i'm not talking
about hunter biden anymore we've we've
moved on
first
let us discuss
the fact that some of us
are actually adults right many of us are
adults and when you're an adult that
means that you need life insurance
because god forbid you're walking down
the street and a car comes right at you
and you jump out of the way to avoid the
car and you jump directly into a manhole
and it's 10 feet deep and you fall down
into the manhole and you break your legs
and it turns out that you cannot crawl
out as there is a wave of sewage that
just washes you away right if any of
that were to happen you need life
insurance right i mean and that's why
you need policy genius policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place why compare well you could say 50
or more in life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you could save
1300 bucks or more per year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare your policies
i love this ad too much the licensed
experts at policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one buy
forbes higher than options from ladder
bestow and ethos it's really easy head
on over to policygenius.com
shapiro right now and get started policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice very important an adult to get it
right okay so
well hunter biden is going around
inflating his own finances as well as
his genitals it turns out that his
father is just busy inflating the
economy according to the wall street
journal we now have another terrible
inflationary report according to the
wall street journal inflation remained
elevated in july as the economic
recovery continued but prices showed
evidence of cooling amid
pandemic-related supply problems and
signs that the recent rise in
coronavirus infections is starting to
crimp some business activity
so it sounds like a great time to blow
more money into the economy we have a
massive inflation rate we have a drop
off in demand oh goody goody gumdrops
this is called stagflation when you have
an inflation in the price but a drop-off
in the demand this is called step stag
nation in fl stagflation okay that's it
that's how that word comes to be so that
is what we are starting to look at
perhaps consumer prices rose 5.4 in july
from a year earlier the same pace as in
june this is the highest 12-month rate
since 2008 the labor department reported
on wednesday
on a monthly basis the price pressures
did weaken the department's consumer
price index climbed a seasonally
adjusted 0.5 in july from june that's a
significantly slower pace than the 0.9
percent increase in june from may okay
so there are a bunch of problems
happening right now one is coveted
related some people are not going back
to work another problem that we are
experiencing right now is a continued
price inflation and then the biggest
problem of all is what happens if we
just don't have systemic demand this is
what happened throughout the 1990s in
japan so throughout the 1980s japan was
supposed to be the the place that was on
the make japan was going to overtake the
united states and then it turns out the
demand dropped off and they just had
stagnation for like a decade and they
really have never recovered the japanese
economy
the the idea of secular stagnation
i've talked about on the program before
that is actually a greater threat at
this point to the
the possible growth of the american
economy than inflation is
but
inflation is still a major problem for
many many americans and so joe biden
said no no this is a good monthly report
everything is fine guys it's fine
everything's good
the latest report on consumer price
shows
prices show
that we've expanded some easy now excuse
me the expected easy we thought was
going to come has increased
that we are we've seen a good monthly
report the monthly core consumer price
index
is down by nearly two-thirds
from its pace over the past three months
okay so he's picking and choosing which
prices supposedly matter when he looks
at the consumer price index jen saki
said the same thing she said core
inflation is fine it's just over the
margins that we're having inflationary
problems
really is it here is john saki
if you actually look at the numbers and
the trends over the last several months
it shows that core inflation uh one was
not only below uh expectations but it
decelerated from last month and even
from the month prior so over the last
couple of months uh we actually saw it
trended downward over the last three
months and that is an encouraging sign
okay so they're saying that the
inflation is starting to wane okay
there's only one problem the inflation
that is already baked in because you
guys are pouring money into the economy
is resulting in a lot of people not
going back to work according to the wall
street journal two days ago millions of
americans are unemployed despite record
job openings the hardest-hit industries
have yet to get back to the pre-pandemic
levels according to the wall street
journal the number of available jobs
since may has outnumbered americans
looking for work one factor is a mitch
mismatch between where people want to
work and which industries are hiring the
hardest hit industries have yet to
recover to pre-pandemic levels when 63
of americans were in the labor force in
july there are 5.7 million fewer jobs on
a seasonally adjusted basis than there
were in february of 2020 according to
labor department data the number of
people trying to get back into the
workforce has rebounded since the early
days of the pandemic the share of adults
working or looking for a job has
increased slightly from a low of 60.2
percent in april of last year to 61.7
percent in july
however what this means is that there
are millions of jobs that are going
unfilled right now
employers still have 6.6 million fewer
jobs on the payroll than they did last
year
but there's still 10 million job
openings from june
okay and if those were filled we'd be
back above where we were before the
pandemic started but those jobs aren't
being filled because people are being
told to stay home
okay there is a there's a serious hold
up in the economy and that is pouring
all this money into the economy right
now and it's affecting people on a
pretty day-to-day level tyson foods for
example just raised its prices to keep
up with inflation this is how inflation
works by the way when there is too much
money chasing too few products everybody
has to raise prices to compensate
according to reuters tyson foods cannot
increase prices for chicken and prepared
foods fast enough to keep pace with
rising costs for raw materials like rain
chief executive donnie king said on
monday after the company reported higher
than expected quarterly earnings we have
lots of reports right now that are being
cheered by the left reports about how
employers are offering these insane
benefits to get people to work and isn't
that just wonderful isn't that just
great well that's great up until the
point where the demand falls off in
which case all those people get fired
right that is the problem with
stagnation
if you are artificially increasing the
economy and telling people to come home
or tell people to stay home they won't
come to work unless you offer them these
exorbitant benefits the exorbitant
benefits come with price increases but
what happens when the demand levels off
because the stimulus is stopped because
you can't just do quantitative easing
forever
or can you
apparently the biden administration kind
of thinks that you can by the way this
is pretty incredible the white house is
now
noticing that gasoline prices have been
heavily on the rise we're just in
california and in california the gas
prices are in excess of five bucks a
gallon which is just insane that's a
really really high price
well president biden he admits that the
gas prices he says that they're lower
than they were you know 10 years ago but
they're still really really high right
now
today gas prices are lower than they
were early in this decade but they're
still high enough to create a pinch on
working families
one key thing about the infrastructure
bill that just passed the senate is
there are no
gas tax increases
no gas tax increases i made that
absolutely clear that i would not raise
gas taxes i'm glad everyone in the
senate seemed to agree with that i have
a question why not i was informed the
gas is really really bad for the
environment
in fact it turns out that the white
house is now calling on opec and its oil
producing allies to boost production in
an effort to combat climate and gasoline
prices but i was told by the left that
climbing gasoline prices are a good that
is a good thing isn't it right i thought
that the price inflation we're seeing
that's just that's not a reflection of
inflation
that is a reflection of all the pent-up
demand so if that's the case why are you
trying to artificially decrease oil
prices wouldn't it be good for oil
prices to remain high from an
environmental perspective after all that
would create the market incentive for
people to get with the green energy
program but joe biden is not willing to
risk that because joe biden understands
the reality here which is that the
fundamentals of the economy are still
quite problematic and that when you
inflate the economy you end up blowing
up the price of gas and there are a lot
of people out there who still need the
gas
and so instead he is carving a hole in
his entire environmental agenda by going
direct to opec and asking them to
increase the supply of oil in order to
lower the price it's worth pointing out
the hypocrisy of the biden
administration they're all for green
energy until comes the point when the
price of gasoline rises at which point
they immediately say no gas taxes and
also opec do you mind you know cranking
up the production just a little bit
meanwhile is the senate slowing down at
all not for one iota of a moment
according to just the news dot com the
democrat led senate has now okayed more
than four trillion dollars of spending
in less than 24 hours
they voted to authorize all of this over
the last
24 hours to send it past 1.2 trillion
dollar infrastructure bill that includes
517 billion in new spending and a
reauthorization of funding from the
highway bill the senate then moved to
debate on the democrats filibuster-proof
3.5 trillion budget reconciliation
proposal the framework for the plan
authorizing that level of federal
spending passed in a 50 to 49 vote early
wednesday morning at 3 50 a.m
the reconciliation bill includes new
spending programs related to
tuition-free community college which is
a terrible idea universal pre-k support
for child care medicaid expansion it
contains tax increases like a corporate
tax rate hike to pay for part of the
bill once the proposal is turned into
formal legislative language it will be
put up for a final vote on the senate
floor it can only pass if all the
democrats vote in favor of it and the
democrats are making clear that this is
exactly what they want to do in fact
house democrats are already threatening
that they're not going to vote for the
infrastructure plan the bipartisan
infrastructure plan unless they get
precisely what they want which is this
3.5 trillion dollar boondoggle of a
budget
so we're just going to continue throwing
money into the system even as inflation
rise it rises and even as the demand
seems to be stagnating which is what is
causing a crimp in the inflation right
now
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the greatest indicator that our congress
just doesn't know what the hell it is
doing and that they see everything it's
just a grab bag of cash for themselves
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk about something that
can make your home look great and not
cost you a fortune i am talking about
changing your window coverings
blinds.com they make it simple to shop
top quality custom blinds shades and
interior shutters from home with easy
online ordering and free shipping the
experts at blinds.com understand that
window treatments are one of those
household items you don't just think
about but they can make a huge impact on
the look and feel of your home you don't
need to do a full renovation by simply
changing what is on the windows you can
change the way light comes into your
home and create a totally different feel
head on over to blinds.com take a look
at all the options like faux wood blinds
cellular and roller shades even outdoor
shades all customizable to your specific
dimensions if you're nervous about
trying them their sure fit guarantee has
you covered blinds.com they've helped
millions of homeowners through the
process plus they guarantee that perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
the measure and install everything for
you i really appreciate having great
sets of blinds in my home you will too
it makes a huge difference on the way
that light comes into your home which is
a big big thing go right now see how
much you can save at blinds.com when you
check out online don't forget to tell
them you heard about blinds.com from the
ben shapiro show rules and restrictions
may apply alrighty meanwhile as we speak
about this the infrastructure bill
passed by a huge margin a bunch of
republicans voted in favor and now moves
to that democratic lead house senate
republican leader mitch mcconnell joined
the democrats in voting for the bill
the bill passed 69 to 30. so a bunch of
republicans voted in favor of this bill
this bill by the way includes the first
step toward the government really
cracking down on cryptocurrency now i
know a lot of people don't understand
what cryptocurrency is it's kind of
confusing right if you don't understand
what cryptocurrency is i have a youtube
video that you definitely should check
out where i go through what bitcoin is
and what the roots of it are and all of
that suffice to say what cryptocurrency
really is is a threat to the fiat
currency regime of the united states and
other countries cryptocurrency allows
people to trade with each other without
having to resort to currencies that can
be inflated by centralized government
and also they act as a repository of
value sort of like gold right because
basically what bitcoin is for example is
it is a digital form of it's basically a
digital code that
churns out
so-called coins like regularized
intervals
and then does not do any more than that
right and and there's a whole system by
which the the ownership of these coins
is verified and all of that but the the
main kind of cachet of the thing is is
that is a trustless system it doesn't
require you to go to a bank you don't
have to have a bank account in order to
use bitcoin or you have a wallet that's
it you don't have to worry about
transferring your bitcoin from one
currency into another currency and so
this is a threat to a lot of governments
because government's like for you to use
dollars or it's the yuan or the renminbi
if you're talking about the chinese
government they like for you to use
centralized currencies because this is
how they get out of their debt problem
every time a government racks up a
mounds a monster debt what they do is
they inflate their currency and they
just start slowly inflating their way
out of that debt bitcoin provides an
alternative to that it also by the way
disintermediates like the entire banking
system it really is kind of incredible
you don't think about how when you use
your credit card every time you use your
credit card there are between seven and
ten companies that are involved in every
single use of your credit card
and by the way it takes like days for
every credit card transaction to
actually be verified which is why you'll
get a call from your fraud company two
days after you've used your credit card
on a particular transaction
so there are all sorts of middlemen that
are cut out of the process by bitcoin by
cryptocurrencies generally and
cryptocurrencies are becoming ever more
sophisticated this is really cool stuff
what it is more than anything
is it's an
almost anarchic decentralization of a
process that the elitists in our society
believe they should have control over
and not you so what is government doing
about this well what government could be
doing in the united states is using
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies as a way to
break the chinese financial stranglehold
on that part of the world because
chinese citizens right now have to trade
using the yuan for example right they
have to trade using digital currencies
that are being created by the chinese
government but what if they didn't have
to what if they could trade straight in
dollars what if the united states for
example created its own fed coin or
pushed forward stable coin which is tied
to the price of the dollar well then the
chinese would be in real trouble but the
american government is too stupid to see
this so instead what you get is them
attempting to undermine cryptocurrencies
because those cryptocurrencies could
theoretically be a threat to america's
ability to be the world currency and
america's ability to
blow out the spending and then inflate
their way out of it later
okay which is why it makes it kind of
troubling that along with this
infrastructure package according to
quartz.com the u.s senate passed a 1
trillion infrastructure bill on tuesday
with a glaring problem for the
cryptocurrency industry the bill
includes vague new tax reporting
requirements that digital rights
advocates say threaten individual
privacy and crypto advocates say could
hamstring industry innovation in the
united states the bill's authors focused
on closing the crypt the so-called
crypto tax gap to pay for some of the
massive spending plan bottom line is
this there are a lot of people who are
using crypto to trade there are a lot of
people who are buying crypto
and the government doesn't like that
you're making money and so the
government wants to take that money away
from you and they want to penalize you
for engaging in a system that rivals the
united states dollar in some ways even
though it is not nearly big enough to
rival the us dollar in any real sense
even though not enough companies have
adopted the ability to pay with bitcoin
yet for it even to be seen as a as a
true kind of global currency in the same
way that the us dollar is
when government sees a thing that is
successful government's first move is
how can i steal that money and use it to
my own benefit and that is what they're
doing with cryptocurrency the bill
requires any crypto broker defined as
anyone responsible for and regularly
providing any service effectuating
transfer of digital assets on behalf of
another person to report users names and
addresses that leaves all sorts of
players in the crypto space including
miners and software developers on the
hook even though many of them do not
currently gather or access personal
information about users many of whom are
anonymous
like suffice it to say
there is a wide
scale understanding this is a bad piece
of legislation
right the people who are attempting to
push back against this by the way
were people
ranging from the far left like ron wyden
in oregon all the way to ted cruz on the
right
anyone with any semblance of
understanding bitcoin and cryptocurrency
was against what this bill did
they pushed forward with the bill anyway
and they pushed forward with it because
in the end congress does not care what
sort of innovation they stifle congress
does not care what industries they
strangle in the crib they don't care
about any of that stuff all they care
about is how can they grab your cash
that's it
the original language by the way of the
bill there were amendments that were
proposed
but those amendments were put to the
side because it was important that
nothing be amended so that they could
pass this stupid infrastructure bill
it's it's a huge problem for crypto the
administration for it for its own sake
it has said well you know in the end
we're probably not going to enforce it
the way you guys fear we're going we're
going to enforce it but bottom line is
this once you hand that sort of power to
bureaucrats it's only it's like
chekhov's gun once it's above the mantle
it will be used at some point in a way
that you don't particularly like
alrighty coming up we'll get to the
latest in everything at covet related
first let us talk about the greatest
underwear on the planet i'm talking of
course about tommy john they grace this
magnificent tourist at this particular
moment and they can grace your success
as well and let me just tell you these
underwear are spectacular apollo men's
underwear it's proven to keep you drier
and up to seven degrees cooler than
regular cotton underwear which is why
tommy john doesn't have customers they
have fanatics apollo underwear soft
supportive stretches for the perfect fit
every day is available up to size 4xl
with over 15 million pairs sold men
across america love tommy john underwear
and like all tommy john underwear apollo
comes with the best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee tommy john's
new apollo men's underwear is high end
for your rear end you can't get them
anywhere else i already told you i took
all the other underwear that i had after
i started using tommy john i threw them
out because they're just they just don't
compare they there's no comparison but
one of the things i love about tommy
john's they're extremely durable you can
throw them in the wash a thousand times
and they come out like with the same
quality that you had the first time you
tried them on right now get 20 off your
first order at tommyjohn.com
ben go to tommyjohn.com
for 20 off that's tommyjohn.com
see site for detailed alrighty meanwhile
the
fanaticism on covid continues
now there is new data out about covid
and the vaccines the new data suggests
that the pfizer vaccine
is
not supremely effective when it comes to
preventing infection against delta we
already knew this right we knew in
israel for example there was some data
that suggested that the pfizer vaccine
was only 30 something percent effective
against the transmission of delta among
the vaccinated right that you could get
a breakthrough case
fairly easily even if you were
vaccinated in israel
here's the thing
who cares who cares let me reiterate who
cares wants more i don't care you
shouldn't care
cases don't matter cases are irrelevant
how many cases of colds were there in
the united states last year any idea i
don't have any idea you know why i don't
care you don't care either you know why
it's a cold
okay once you have had the vaccine covet
is now downgraded to the level of a mild
flu at worst or a cold the levels of
death from covid yes with the delta
variants are extremely extremely low
so who cares that you can transmit it or
they can get it pretty easily if you've
already had the vaccine i don't care
that i can get a cold i still walk
around without a mask in normal everyday
life
as should you
okay what this actually should say is
okay well since everybody who has had
the vaccine can still get this thing and
then presumably still transmit it
although we don't have the full data on
transmission yet
even if that's the case what that really
means is there is no way we're getting
to zero covered zero covert is not a
thing that's going to happen and so
everybody should go and live their lives
now
that's what that actually means
and yet the idea from the left is that
they have a way to shut this down and
they don't they just don't it's just
about control at this point that's the
part that's totally maddening
no one has a way to prevent a future
variant if a future variance is coming
it's coming
no one has a way to prevent this thing
from transmitting because literally
hundreds of millions of human beings
have had this thing at this point
okay in fact the only country right now
that i'm aware of that has had no real
delta surge in terms of death is sweden
okay is that is there any wonder for
that like i'm looking right now at
sweden's case right okay sweden's
coveted cases
they they just have not had any surge
period end of story
sweden starting in july went down to
about 230 213 somewhere in the 200 to
300 case a day range
okay right now they are up to like a 700
cases a day range their chart is
extremely mild they are not seeing a
giant spike in sweden could that have
something to do with the fact that they
pursued a very floridian strategy of
shield the vulnerable and let everybody
else go to work
largely without masks
is that a possibility
one of the things that we now know
according to israeli studies is that
natural immunity may be more durable
than vaccine immunity
and nonetheless the idea here is that if
you want people to live any form of real
life if you want people to get back to
work at any point if you want anyone to
go back to normal at any point it is
because you are selfish and terrible
that's because we are now engaged in a
bizarre single factor analysis where the
only thing we care about is preventing
transmission of covet
that's stupid
it's really dumb
i was talking with someone today at
length about this particular issue and
he was saying well don't you
why do you have different answers than
so many of the public health specialists
i said first of all it depends which
ones you talk to have you talked to
mario mccary over at johns hopkins or if
you talk to jay about acharya over at
stanford
even to talk to former cdc director
robert redfield even by the way if you
talk to former fda commissioner scott
golly
they all agree with a lot of what the
things that i'm saying but put that
aside
maybe the reason that i disagree with so
many public health experts is not
because we are looking at different data
maybe we're looking at the same data but
their priority is not my priority their
priority is no one should ever get
coveted again and my priority is people
should be allowed to live free now that
the risk has been mitigated to the
fullest possible extent available for
normal human beings
okay this is why it is so maddening to
me when you are seeing for example the
the gensakes and joe bidens of the world
attacking ron desantis the governor of
florida it is absolutely maddening to me
because if you look once again at the
death rate from covid in florida overall
florida still ranks like 26th in the
pack
florida never should have been the
bugaboo they have the second oldest
state in the country and again the
oldest day because i don't really count
maine maine again has seven people in
the moose
okay so the fact that that six of those
people are old means nothing florida has
a
bevy of old people florida's an
extremely elderly
an elderly populated state
and the stance is still
without the population adjustments ranks
like 26th in terms of deaths per 100
000. the media are not interested in
telling you that they're interested in
ripping onto santas and the answer is
because desantis like you like me like
many americans is trying to balance a
variety of factors when it comes to
covid and those factors do include
things like do i really need to mask my
kid when they go to school in the united
states fewer than 400 children have died
under the age of 18 a subgroup of 73
plus million americans
okay there is no evidence that delta is
more deadly for kids than the prior
variants that is according to joe
biden's own administration
that evidence does not exist that's nih
director francis collins saying that
himself
the evidence when it comes to masking in
classrooms does not exist
it doesn't exist we talked about this
yesterday there is no comparative
masking in classrooms versus non-masking
classroom study that demonstrates that
masking in classrooms is deeply
effective in preventing some sort of
cataclysm that's to come
okay but
if you don't care about any of those
priorities if your only priority is no
one should ever get sick again the
answer is going to be john travolta and
the bubble boy and that's what these
folks want
this is why gen saki is trying to make
an enemy of ron desantis like listen to
gensake it's pretty wild
a headline from the new york post
from i believe uh two days ago team
biden's war on desantis is all about
kneecapping a successful governor a gop
governor could you address that concern
please our work uh is not on desantis
it's on the virus uh which we're trying
to kneecap uh and uh he does not seem to
want to participate in that effort to
kneecap the virus hence our concern
screw you he doesn't want to participate
in
on what planet
93 of florida seniors have had at least
one dose of the vaccine and well over 80
percent of seniors in florida have had
two doses of the vaccine he doesn't want
to kneecap the virus no it's just that
he does not believe that it is possible
to completely kill off the virus because
there's no evidence it's possible to
completely kill off the virus worldwide
okay you're lying okay you're just lying
everyone would like to see fewer people
die
there are other priorities that must be
balanced there
okay just as there always are in
politics the most ridiculous stupid and
corrupt game in politics is if it saves
just one life
because that can apply to literally
anything if it would save just one life
we could outlaw all cars if it would
save just one life we could lock you in
your home permanently if it would save
just one life then we could make sure
that no one ever walked outside their
front door forever we could do that
no one's willing to do that
priorities have to be balanced
but of course the white house doesn't
want to balance those priorities
so instead they're just promoting as
much sort of lockdown
nonsense as they possibly can we'll get
to that in just one moment first let us
talk about the fact that you really
don't need to go to an auto parts store
pretty much ever because you have the
interwebs it's a great place
rockauto.com
it's so much easier than walking into a
store and somebody's demanding quick and
specific answers to the car part that
you need takes you 20 minutes to figure
it out finally the guy behind the
counter is like okay but we don't have
it in stock bro you're gonna have to
order it and um
plus twenty percent it'll be three weeks
or you could just go to rockauto.com and
get the cheaper price and it'll come
directly to your door so why wouldn't
you just do that makes a lot more sense
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockladder.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brand's
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockladder.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro and there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you again that's rockauto.com
no reason for you to head on over to the
auto parts store to do everything you
need on the magical interwebs at
rockauto.com
right now alrighty we'll get to more of
the democrats lockdown mentality
politics again it is not rooted in
evidence first
your reminder the authoritarian moment
is here not just like my book but
actually like the authoritarian moment
like we are experiencing
authoritarianism for your state and
local governments we're experiencing it
from the top levels of the abiding
administration and of course we are
experiencing it from all of america's
major institutions if you want to know
how things got this bad and more
importantly how to fight back you need
my book the authoritarian moment there's
number four on the new york times
bestseller list again this week
continues to sell like
insane numbers of copies join the
movement against the authoritarian
moment by buying a copy of the
authoritarian moment right now at amazon
barnes noble or any other major
bookseller go get your copy right now
leave a five star review if you like
what you read also you'll remember
there's no secret that candace owns it
knows how to light up twitter but if you
haven't heard she is now opening her
studio to one lucky vip winner it's
pretty spectacular stuff if you sign up
right now as a daily wire member with
code vip you get 25 off your new
membership and you're automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two you and a guest to the daily wire
studios to see candace live not only
will you meet candace you'll get an
inside look at her studio and front row
seats to watch her take down leftist
live and in action on her talk show
canvas so get a great deal on a new
daily wire membership at dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip and 25 off so
you can automatically be entered for a
chance to win that vip experience
other news we've had a lot to celebrate
here at daily wear including the massive
success of our newest podcast the
morning wire intends on supplying
americans with a daily dose of nothing
but the fact it's been topping the apple
and spotify charts since its recent
release it's the only daily news podcast
that values your time and the actual
honest-to-god truth while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
subscribe start listening right now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a 5 star review if you like what
you hear it's brought to you by
dailywear editor and chief john bickley
and co-host georgia howe morningwire
will wake you up with latest
developments in politics sports culture
and education all with a heavy emphasis
on the fact in 15 bite size minutes
perfect for your daily commute again
subscribe and listen to morning wire on
apple podcast spotify and everywhere you
listen to podcasts so you don't miss a
beat if you like what you hear leave a 5
star review tell the podcast platforms
conservative news belongs at number one
on the charts you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
well in the absence of evidence and also
in the absence of any sort of real moral
case for why they're doing what they're
doing the democrats the left across the
board their basic idea here is to just
imply that everybody they don't like
wants people to die right we're back to
where we were at the beginning of the
pandemic when people were saying we
really need to take into account all of
the countervailing factors and people
are saying well you just want to kill
grandma we're right back there it never
waned and right now the only thing that
they keep saying over and over and over
again is that they
want zero covet and zero code is not a
thing it is just
not a thing so instead they're not
talking about all the dictatorial
measures they're going to take so
jensaki said we are lifting up and
supporting private sector vaccination
mandates
okay now let's just recall this is the
federal government talking about how it
wants private industries to do what the
federal government itself will not do
right that's what this is this is the
exact same thing as when the federal
government says they want facebook to
ban particular types of speech now
they're saying what we would really like
is for all of these corporations to do
what we're not doing and mandate the
vaccines
remember still fda emergency use
authorization i am very much pro-vaccine
in fact here's the thing i'm more
pro-vaccine than any of these people you
know why because now that i've had the
vaccine i'm done i'm done and that means
that i don't care whether you have the
vaccine or not i mean i'd prefer that
you do for your own peace of mind for
your own safety but if you choose not to
get the vaccine it doesn't affect me
because all that's going to happen to me
in all likelihood and when i say in all
likelihood i mean in 99.99 of cases all
that's going to happen to me if i get a
breakthrough case is i will have the
sniffles
which is perfectly acceptable to me that
is a massive downgrade from the
possibility that i was going to die from
this thing or that my parents were going
to die from this thing
okay so i care like again i have more
faith in the vaccines than any of these
people apparently and yet they're the
ones who are saying they want to
cuddle corporations into doing what they
won't do
it's a front doorway of lifting up
private sector companies who are taking
steps uh through carrots and sticks
through incentives uh and through
mandates in some cases to get more
people vaccinated and to
make sure they're protecting their
workforce i would note that this was
intentionally a diverse group of
industries so the airline industry
university systems healthcare industry
small businesses we wanted to share the
work they're doing
and support these efforts and today is
an example of uh us lifting up the
private sector taking steps that make
sense
funny how they're in favor of the
private sector when the private sector
is being hijacked by them to do what
they want when sean penn is talking
about how corporations need to mirror
sean penn you should be very afraid sean
penn is a dude who hangs out he like he
he gave a eulogy for hugo for hugo
chavez okay this is not somebody who is
congenitally pro corporation this is
somebody who's happy with corporations
when they do his bidding
this is one of those things that should
be mandatory that that that we all get
with the exception the very few
exceptions of those people who
for for whatever the medical condition
might
offset it but i do think that vaccines
that need to be mandatory and i do think
that business all businesses movie
business all business need to uh take
the lead
okay it's funny how all the people on
the left who hate corporations and
believe the corporations are the root of
all evil now want corporations to take
the lead how strange how strange
meanwhile it's getting dystopian out
there so youtube apparently has now
suspended rand paul for the great sin of
questioning the efficacy of masks this
is according to just the news quote
kentucky republican senator rand paul
announced tuesday he has been censored
by youtube which he described as
becoming a quote unquote arm of the
government he told just the news tuesday
on a conference call we've had two
speeches taken down this last one was i
think a short speech the access to the
entire youtube channel is no longer
available recently i shared a video on
my youtube page it was an interview
between myself and a journalist where we
discussed a variety of topics including
the science behind wearing masks
apparently because i dared to contradict
dr fauci in the government youtube has
removed my video youtube said the video
violated their policy because of my
comments on masks and that they don't
allow videos that contradict
government's guidance on kovid
youtube may be a private entity but
they're acting like an arm of the
government censoring those who present
an alternative view to the science
deniers in washington so who exactly are
they going to listen to then right who
exactly are they going to censor are
they going to answer zeke emmanuel zeke
emmanuel is a covert advisor to
president biden
zeke emanuel is one of the architects of
obamacare here he was yesterday saying
cloth masks aren't good enough against
delta by the way i'm
right now as i mentioned we're in hawaii
they put the mask mandates back on
you're supposed to be wearing the masks
literally everywhere including like on
the beach and out in public like it's
crazy it's totally insane okay and most
of the people who i haven't seen wearing
masks are wearing either surgical masks
or cloth masks
okay that is likely according to joe
biden's own sources to not be
particularly effective
i'm not saying it you want to ban zika
manual ban zika manual okay here's the
manual saying that
wearing gators or just simple cloth
masks are not good enough and getting uh
n95 is good it's also important to make
sure you're getting an n95 that's niosh
approved there are lots of fakes out
there about 60 percent of the kn 95s
appear to be counterfeit
and a lot of them not made to uh the
high standards of 95 protection but i
totally agree with you andrea that we do
need to up our game it's not just
masking it's proper masking including
the nose and it's masking with a good
mask like an n95 okay can i mention
something about canon 95s so i asked my
wife about this because she had to take
classes with regards to how you properly
wear personal protective equipment right
when you're in a hospital
you are supposed to change your kn95
every time you leave a patient
every single patient you're supposed to
change your can95 have you ever seen
anyone operate this way
people wear the can 95 the same one for
like weeks on end right they go home
they take it off because they're
expensive they put them back on and then
they wear it the next day
throughout the day they take them off
they'll put them in their back pocket
while they're eating they'll take them
out of their back pocket like they're
put
again this does go to questions of
efficacy it's not just zika manual by
the way michael osterholm is a former
biden advisor on clover he says the
exact same thing
we know that face cloth coverings can
reduce the amount of virus that you may
inhale but to be fully protected in the
way that we believe with particularly
with this variant that we have today
delta you need to have the kind of
protection that comes with nin 95 or a k
in 95 for kids which are available in in
children's sizes and just it's putting
something over your face and of itself
doesn't protect you now that doesn't
give anybody license to take my
statement and say masking doesn't work
is what you have to do is use effective
masking and we have done a poor job of
communicating that and i think cdc is is
in part responsible for that yes they're
they're entirely responsible for that in
part entirely and by the way kn kn95 for
kids
kn95s for are you out of your damned
minds have you ever met a five-year-old
what are you talking about
there's still
no verifiable data suggesting that
masking in school mandatorily has
lowered case rates anywhere
that data does not exist because there's
no comp group we talked about this
yesterday there are some places that did
it there are some places that didn't the
comps don't exist
maybe it helps maybe it doesn't the one
thing that we know for a fact is that
very
unbelievably low number of kids have
been killed by covid
thank god thank god for that and now
you're trying to mask up my
seven-year-old in perpetuity
for the risk that she by the way a risk
that lower than the risk that she was
going to die of the flu
right that
this is much less deadly than the flu
for small children
not for everybody for everybody else is
more deadly than the flu for small
children is less deadly than the flu
okay as ron desantis points out by the
way it is amazing what we do what we
know and what we don't at this point
with regard to culvert it is truly
incredible you understand then the
united states we still have no me had no
idea how many americans actually had
coveted
we have no idea isn't that kind of a
bizarre like if i ask you how many
americans had covered you would not know
the answer you know who else wouldn't
know the answer the nih the nih did zero
serious national zero prevalence studies
you can tell who had it in britain
britain tested people they did antibody
tests and so they know how close they
are to hurt immunity we have no idea how
many people actually got covered over
the course of this pandemic that's
insane a lot of parents have have come
they've come to me they've come to their
school boards and said this has been
very difficult on their young kids to
have to sit there for eight hours with
this it's not natural it's never been
studied what the effects of that are you
know nih has a 42 billion dollar budget
they've not spent a single penny since
covet started studying uh how these
mitigations affect kids so ultimately my
view is it's a parent's decision okay
and it should be a parent's decision but
apparently it's not supposed to be
because in the end your freedom is of
very little concern to our
great public health overlords here's
arnold schwarzenegger saying that you
shouldn't worry about your freedom
anymore you don't need your freedom it's
not important anymore helga enough
there is a virus here it kills people
and the only way we prevented this is to
get vaccinated to wear masks to do
social distancing washing your hands all
the time and not just to think about
well my freedom is being kind of
disturbed here no screw your freedom
because with freedom comes obligations
and uh and have responsibilities we
cannot just say i have the right to the
x y and z when you affect other people
that is when you get serious they have
the freedom to wear no mask but you know
something you're a schmuck for not
wearing a mask
give up your freedom if you want to live
come with me
like what in the
no
again you wanna this is like saying that
i am somehow responsible
for you
after i put on my seat belt in my car
what i really need to do is i need to
strap a mattress to the front of my car
in case you didn't in case you decided
you didn't want to wear your seatbelt
and you go crashing through the front
windshield of your car in a car crash i
need to drive around with a mattress on
the front of my car to make sure that it
catches you in case you didn't wear your
your seatbelt
okay this is
it's it's amazing and not only that we
got to do this for your kids we got to
do this very important we do this for
your kids how insane has this become the
new south wales health minister woman
named kerry chance is in australia she
came out and she said if you see other
people try not to talk to them
try not to have conversations with other
humans
what in the act what is going on
we've all lost our minds by the way the
total number of cases in new south wales
in australia right now
their seven day rolling average is 312
cases the population of new south wales
is 8.166
million humans
again total case count is in the 300s
and she's saying don't talk to any of
the other 8 million people living around
you because you might give them kovid
this is so
that
what
their their daily their seven day daily
death average in new south wales right
now
is two
two
you've all lost your mind i'm sorry
you've all gone crazy
whilst it is a human nature to engage in
conversation with others
to be friendly
unfortunately this is not the time to do
that so even if you run into your next
door neighbour
in the shopping center in the coles
while you're at kohl's wars or aldi or
any other grocery shop
don't start up a conversation
now is the time for minimizing your
interactions with others
this is insane by the way israel is
doing the same thing israel is also
crazy the cabinet in israel just voted
to expand what they call the green pass
to all branches of the economy except
malls and places of commerce it will
apply starting at the age
of three
now you may be asking yourself wait a
second i thought kids couldn't get the
vaccine yet they can't
what does this mean it means that anyone
who's unvaccinated including small
children will now be required to present
a negative covid test before going to a
swimming pool gym academic institution
sport and cultural event conference
museum library restaurant or hotel
so if i want to take my five-year-old to
a restaurant in israel i have to present
a negative covid test
presumably one from the last couple of
days
the test for children up to 11 will be
paid for by the state whereas anyone 12
or older will be required to fund the
screening on their own
um the entire world has lost their minds
they've lost their minds they've lost
their minds they've no connection with
reality anymore
everybody is so s you talk about the
rise of safety ism this is the triumph
of safetyism it's over for freedom if
people have the perception of safety
that a vaccine is out there you can
protect yourself and we still have to
lock down every aspect of society
including talking to other people and
basic freedom according to arnold
schwarzenegger and not masking children
and also you know like going to a
restaurant with your kids this is nuts
all righty we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more in the meantime have
yourself a wonderful evening also coming
up soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30
pm eastern be sure to check it out over
at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode
vaccine passports are on the rise the
showdown between texas republicans and
democrats heats up and the california
recall election titans join us and get
the facts first on the news you need to
know with our show morning wire